>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Hello everyone,
I'm Juan Felipe Herrera
US Poet Laureate.
I'm here at the Library of
Congress in the Hispanic Division
and I have here Georgette Dorn
who is the Chief of the Division.
Hi, Georgette.
What can you tell us
about what's going on?
What's new?
>> Georgette Dorn: We have some
wonderful materials from Cuba.
This is called Ediciones Vigía
that began publishing in 1985
in Matanzas, Cuba by
Rolando Rodríguez.
And they are very unique
artists materials
on common paper, illustrated
by artists.
And they had major
poets cited, Borges.
>> Herrera: Borges,
Jorge Luis Borges.
>> Dorn: Federico García
Lorca, Emily Dickinson and it is
on common paper but it is also
supplemented with natural materials
like string, seashells...
>> Herrera: Seashells?
>> Dorn: Yes, it's very Cuban
and at the beginning the
government didn't really like it,
but now they are really
protecting it.
And these little artist books have
found their way to the Library
of Congress, to the British Library,
and to the many university
libraries.
This is an example of
materials that are used
on common paper, wonderfully
illustrated.
>> Herrera: Yes, and do
they make their own paper?
>> Dorn: No, but they
use very natural papers.
But they use their own
ink and their own poetry.
This is a homage to the workers on
the [inaudible] River for instance.
>> Herrera: Oh, look at that.
>> Dorn: So this is an extraordinary
collection and the Library
of Congress actually has the
biggest Vigía collection.
And it began at the old colonial
house of Vigía in Matanzas, Cuba.
So it's, right now they are like
you know they are keeping them
in Rare Books actually.
This is part of our
Rare Book Collection.
>> Herrera: It's beautiful
and who was Vigía?
Who was Vigía?
>> Dorn: But that was just
a house called Vigía.
>> Herrera: It's a
house called Vigía.
>> Dorn: A colonial
house Vigía in Matanzas,
Cuba which is on the eastern,
far eastern side of Cuba.
>> Herrera: On the far eastern side.
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: I really like
them because of the, you know,
common paper and the perhaps, this
kind of, it looks like a paper bag.
>> Dorn: It is.
It is brown paper, yes.
>> Herrera: Brown paper
and then the ink.
Do they have their own presses?
>> Dorn: Yes, they do.
They have their own press
and artists from all
over the world contribute
artwork and poetry
so it has become quite
international since 1985.
>> Herrera: In Matanzas.
>> Dorn: Yes, in Matanzas, Cuba.
>> Herrera: Is it a
small group of artists?
>> Dorn: It began as a small group.
Now it's actually quite large.
It's Island wide.
And as I say, also
from other countries.
They write, they contribute,
they send their poems,
they send their artwork,
so it's very interesting.
There are poems, there
are also essays,
"novelletas," you know,
short novels.
So it's a very large collection.
We have actually thousands of Vigía
books in the Library's collection.
>> Herrera: They are
different sizes.
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: I love this.
>> Dorn: And as you see, they
keep them in very special housing
because they are very fragile.
>> Herrera: I notice it's
not only different materials,
but it's also some kind of
collage, they do collage.
>> Dorn: Yes, it is collage, yes.
Some of them have seashells, some
of them have, you know, strings
and other materials
so it's very...and you
also have to preserve them.
So we do a great emphasis on
preserving them in the proper light
so they will last for a long time.
>> Herrera: Well this is beautiful.
I have seen in another visit to
the Hispanic Division that they had
like a shoebox approach
to a magazine.
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: And this
is more like revista,
open-folded magazine approach?
>> Dorn: It is.
It is like each issue
is completely different.
But it is sort of like
a serial, yeah.
>> Herrera: Yeah, it is.
>> Dorn: And we call it
Colección de Vigía.
>> Herrera: Colección de Vigía.
>> Dorn: And they have
Colección de Lorica and many,
many other famous,
you know, writers.
>> Herrera: I saw that.
This is something everybody can
do, maybe not at this level,
or maybe yes, but this is very
available if we want to do it,
let's say for Casa de
Colores out in the cities
and towns of the United States.
>> Dorn: I think that
would be very nice.
>> Herrera: Don't you think?
>> Dorn: Yeah, if the community
could contribute to it, yes.
>> Herrera: Yes.
>> Dorn: It would be a great effort.
And artists would contribute
very original artwork to it too.
>> Herrera: I think it's a great
thing, you know, we could think
about that and start doing it.
You go to the store and
bring back the paper bag
or whatever bags you bring
back or even the cardboard.
>> Dorn: Yes, this is
actually a paper bag
and then they paste it on...
>> Herrera: I love it!
>> Dorn: ...and then of course it
has to be preserved very much so,
so the glue does not ruin the paper.
So that's where our experts
come in, in Preservation.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Dorn: So, they keep it very...
>> Herrera: And they have the
famous little dust jacket here.
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: With a little bio?
>> Dorn: This is an artist
born, I mean poet born in 1972.
>> Herrera: Poet?
>> Dorn: So his prior work is here.
>> Herrera: Bio.
>> Dorn: And there is his poetry.
>> Herrera: And there's the
poetry, El violinista desnudo.
>> Dorn: The Naked Violinist.
>> Herrera: The Naked Violinist
and then there's other
designs, designios.
>> Dorn: Designs, yes.
>> Herrera: Designs, and
then there's...what is this?
This is the title of
the piece is it?
>> Dorn: Yeah.
>> Herrera: Oficios para el olvido.
>> Herrera: Kind of
Projects for Oblivion.
>> Dorn: Project to Forget.
>> Herrera: Projects to Forget.
>> Dorn: By this very
poet, by Luis Pita García.
>> Herrera: By Luis Pita García.
>> Dorn: And he is
also from Matanzas.
>> Herrera: From Matanzanas.
>> Dorn: One of the
big cities of Cuba.
>> Herrera: Number 36.
>> Dorn: Yes.
Shall we show them Number 36?
>> Herrera: Here's Number 36, folks.
And here's what it
looks like on the back.
And here's what it looks like
with your little, what is this?
>> Dorn: It's a string.
>> Herrera: Just strings,
with some strings,
and you can open it and enjoy.
You can feel it.
How you can feel it really well.
>> Dorn: Yes, I think
it is interesting.
It's Colección de San, Ediciones
Vigía Colección Del San Juan.
And this one is a little bit larger.
>> Herrera: It's larger.
>> Dorn: They are in
different sizes.
>> Herrera: Different sizes.
This one, look it's black.
Look at this, look how
it feels really good.
>> Dorn: Interesting,
interesting paper.
This is very good quality
paper actually.
>> Herrera: Is this
like tissue paper on,
on paper bag, on top of paper bag?
>> Dorn: Yeah.
I think this is like more...
>> Herrera: See?
>> Dorn: More elegant paper, yes.
>> Herrera: Then here's a paper
bag and they put it together?
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: You, see, I know
a little bit of something.
>> Dorn: This is called
Transfiguraciones.
>> Herrera: Transfiguraciones.
>> Dorn: And it is
divided by this very...
>> Herrera: That sounds like
Borges, Transfiguraciones.
Oh, look at that!
>> Dorn: Yeah.
>> Herrera: Look at that!
Look at that.
Look at this.
>> Dorn: Well these poems
have actually won a prize.
The contest was José Jacinto
Milanés of Matanzas in 1997.
>> Herrera: Let's show, let's
show the people what is this,
a dedication, or a note?
>> Dorn: This is prize-winning
poetry by this poet,
by José Jacinto Milanés.
>> Herrera: Okay, the prize-winning
poetry by it's kind of,
it's torn out and then pasted
on top of this tissue paper.
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: See, that's what I like.
It's torn and it's
wrinkled, aesthetically, huh?
>> Dorn: Yeah.
>> Herrera: It's done
with aesthetic feeling.
Wow.
>> Dorn: It has a great
impact actually.
And the author is called
Roberto Manzano Diaz.
>> Herrera: Roberto Manzano Díaz.
>> Dorn: Is the artist...
>> Dorn: Who decorated the poetry.
>> Herrera: Who decorated
the poetry.
Look at, here he is.
>> Dorn: Of José Jacinto Milanés.
>> Herrera: Of José Jacinto
Milanés and there he goes.
1, 2, 3
[ whistles ]
. Thank you very much.
That was great.
>> Dorn: It was a great pleasure.
It's an honor to have you here
at the Library of Congress.
>> Herrera: It's an honor to have
you here at the Library of Congress
as the Head of the
Hispanic Division.
>> Dorn: Yes.
>> Herrera: Thank you
so much, Georgette.
>> Dorn: Thank you.
>> Herrera: Muchas gracias.
>> Dorn: Muchas gracias.
>> Herrera: Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov